in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Daniel
and ever are with us hey guys how are ya
how do you good welcome were you from
Fort Worth Texas all right that's the
howdy I like it yes sir I don't fit
right in in Tennessee I'll just tell you
so good to have you guys
so you're here to do your debt-free
scream yes sir and how much have you
paid off 108 195 thousand two hundred
eighty-five dollars and 35 cents love it
how long did that take you five years
ten months Wow
love it good job and your range of
income through that five years started
at 62,000 ending at $189,000 jump a
little bit so what do you guys do for a
living now I'm a project engineer a
financial analyst okay so what caused
the triple and income in five years went
from one income to two and then several
raises and promotions along the way you
know I was talking to a New York
producer from a show that shall remain
unnamed the other day who called me and
said they wanted to do a segment on the
stagnation of wages in the middle class
and I said well I can probably help you
but the problem is I run into people in
the middle class all the time who aren't
stagnated and you guys obviously didn't
get stagnated did you no no wow
I mean this is pretty incredible
congratulations so what kind of debt was
the 195,000 about 80% of that was
student loans the rest was credit cards
whoa a lot of student loan a lot so like
what is that 150 grand about yes Wow Wow
amazing so what was the degrees in both
got MBAs and supply chain oh okay good
NBA's very good okay great great
good very marketable these days and I
get set you up to win obviously with
your incomes very well done good so what
happened five years ago that puts you on
this get out of debt journey so Dave
this actually goes back nine years ago
when I went I quit my job to do a career
change and as I was exploring graduate
programs I came across your podcast
mm-hmm and as I listened to it I
realized that not only do we need to get
out of debt we had an income problem and
as we were looking at graduate programs
we found one that we were both excited
about and what we decided to do was both
apply for the program figured ok whoever
gets in you get to go in the other one
will work what we didn't anticipate was
that we both would he be accepted into
the program and not only were we
accepted they gave us enough
scholarships and grants to cover
three-quarters of the cost Wow
so we were kind of faced with a dilemma
there you know we we kind of figured
well this is a no brainer we get to go
to school for 1/4 of the cost yeah and
we figured this is great we'll go to
school and once we get out of school
we'll live on one income we'll pay this
off in two years we can do this yep and
so what we didn't take into account Dave
was the fact that we had a two-year-old
and a four-year-old at the tone going to
grad school and those scholarships
didn't cover living expenses childcare
holding fees a details right so that is
where all that debt came from because
our tuition was covered but all the rest
of that debt was just living expenses
for two years you guys completely quit
work both of you went to school at the
same time all time whoa what yes that's
all in yes yes mazing so and then you
turn around graduate and then attack
right and so the major hiccup was of
course we did this in 2008 and we all
remember what was happening to the
economy in 2008 of course so right so
when we enrolled in grad school the
economy hadn't started unraveling yet
they don't teach you about timing and
then ba and so our plan fell apart
because instead of both graduating and
immediately getting jobs at a certain
salary level only one of us got a job
and it was at about 70% of what they
told us we were gonna be our new so our
plan went out the window and for two or
three years we were just treading water
until she got a job as well and then we
were finally able to start that debt
snowball start impacting that curve Wow
Wow the rough two years this is a supply
chain chart for those of you watching on
YouTube for those of you watching it
on the Dave Ramsey show app channel when
you can watch the show up and he's
holding up a classic MBA chart here and
completely had the whole journey is
mapped out this is a actually that needs
to be framed and put in the family
household because that's the that's the
time the family tree changed yeah that's
right
right there right you guys this is
incredible I'm so proud of y'all how
does it feel now that you're the other
side of this mess feels wonderful feels
mean you're making almost 200 a year and
you got no dad yeah yeah it feels
fantastic I was telling her the other
day it feels like we were drowning under
water for almost a decade and I finally
crawled up on the beach and finally
laying there in the Sun just catching my
breath that's pretty good I like that
that's pretty fun so how does it feel
for you ever well at first I kind of was
like a prisoner that had been set free
that didn't know what to do with with
myself I was kind of waiting for the
other shoe to drop
I just didn't know how to take it in and
how to feel it and there was it's not
until maybe the last three weeks or so
that it's finally kind of settling in
that this is a new way of thinking a new
way of living and feels good yeah
absolutely
well when the cash starts piling up that
gets your attention yeah hey this is
cool this worked after all who knew yeah
very fun very fun well we've got a copy
of Chris Hogan's book retire inspired
for you guys because that's the next
step is to build wealth and live like no
one else and give like no one else and
move on through the baby steps from baby
step four and on from now on and finish
paying off the house and all that kind
of stuff well way to go you guys very
very well done your kids are with you
they are ages and names
Samuel age 12 and age 10 all right very
cool now they have any idea what's going
on here they know what's going on yes
yes we've constantly made them aware of
what we were doing why we were doing it
and they had a lot of they we said no to
them a lot
yeah but they've helped us a lot they've
helped us in this journey mm-hmm look it
looks like they've gone fairly unharmed
though yeah they made it through and now
life's getting ready to be very cool
well congratulations you guys all right
Daniel ANOVA Samuel and Sarah Fort Worth
Texas a hundred and ninety five thousand
dollars paid off in five years and ten
months quite a journey making sixty two
up to one eighty nine count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
you guys
that's awesome that is how it's done
right there oh my goodness how wonderful
that's how it works man that's a blast
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or 27 thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or $500,000 in common